you can tell a lot about a person based
on the reaction to fast food sadly I
find these empty calories delicious
that's my curse my blessing is my wife
who slowly steering me towards the
healthy side she's helped me change my
diet with one tasty nuggets no not fat
nugget this one you absorb nutrients
better if things are delicious so poor
dressing on your salad it's for the
greater good why is this important
because the same theory holds true with
learning the chances of me picking up a
non-fiction book about World War one is
incredibly slim but throat pigments in a
fun video game like valiant hearts and I
can learn while having a good time
recently I saw this design principle and
a game centered around Native American
culture a representative of the in you
Piazza
unter folklore the result is never alone
which looks to be the cheesy spread that
makes broccoli even more delicious on
the surface this is a puzzle platformer
with a magical art style you play as a
young girl trying to save her village
from an impending storm and team up with
a courageous Fox along the way you
switch between the characters whenever
you want or have a friend jump right in
this makes never alone a good game for
parents from what to connect with their
children and a fun environment that
promotes learning the puzzles are
relatively simple from what I've seen
the thoughts can bound up walls or climb
through cracks whereas the girl can push
heavy blocks if you're familiar with
puzzles you shouldn't have much problem
but it's still enjoyable it looks so
inviting and the music is so entrancing
that I look forward to each new obstacle
and location the real beauty of never
alone is how it melds this fun adventure
with information about the in ups this
is a folklore that has been passed
through the generations so you'll learn
a lot about the culture there are
spirits hiding in there war borealis so
you must wear a hood to save your own
head and there are animal spirits who
help guide you along if you only care
about the platforming you learn the
basics of what's going on without
knowing the deeper information about
where such beliefs originated but you do
care you can listen to native
storytellers fill in all those little
deep
this is a very similar to what valiant
hearts did in that game I found myself
eagerly reading everything about World
War one often ignoring the game proper
so I could take in all that information
I could see doing the same thing and
never alone keep your eye on this
platformer later this fall looks like
it's avoiding the pitfall of so many
edutainment games on being fun first and
foremost after all you may not eat
Brussels sprouts on their own but douse
them in lemon and garlic and everyone's
happy